[Music]
[Applause]
must win situations starting tonight
is it when ish tonight for the Browns to
the Steelers Louis Riddick former uh NFL
player ESPN analyst he was on the call
in the booth Monday night Steve Levy
they did a great job Dan orlovsky Titans
in the bills Lewis joins us he'll be uh
calling West Virginia at Virginia
Virginia Tech tonight at 7 30 Eastern on
the mothership Lewis let me start with
Brown's Steelers must win or win-ish
game for which team
foreign
I think for both teams it's must win or
win-ish for different reasons
but I think for for Mike Tomlin we're
starting with the Steelers
look Mike's never been below 500 in his
career which is just amazing first and
foremost he's a Hall of Fame worthy
coach just because of his longevity and
his consistency but this may be one of
those
one of those Seasons where he just can't
coach his way out of it we just don't
know whether or not especially
on the offensive side of the ball if
it has taken another step back or it's
at the same level or a little bit better
than next year because we've only played
two games but this team looks
this is this is a little bit scary for
them because they could be in a very
tenuous situation as far as the
quarterback uh situation is concerned
does Mike want to throw can he pick it
in there right now does he not
he look at the offensive line and go
well I don't want to happen
the weeks
or 14 more weeks and and just kind of
and and set him back
and then when you're talking about the
Browns
I think coming into this season
1 through 53
many believe myself included that just
on paper and just when you're looking at
critical positions that you know you
need to have in order to compete at the
high level in the NFL they have them
they have pass rushers they acquired a
wide receiver at some point in time
they'll have you know good quarterback
play they have good secondary players on
the perimeter even in that safety they
have one of the best offensive lines in
football so really what's the issue
well you know you lose the Jets you give
up a lead like you gave up to the Jets
and Joe Flacco and I'm not taking
anything away from Joe Flacco so I saw
him in the preseason and I saw him at
training camp and he was as confident as
ever in their ability to finally not be
considered the same old jet so I'm not
taking anything away from them
but both of these teams for different
reasons one because the expectations
were so high for Cleveland two because
for Pittsburgh Mike's never had a losing
season so yeah I think for both of them
this is a critical game
do you have a take on a team or a couple
of teams where you go what we've seen is
not an aberration that's how they're
going to be
like the Titans you got to see them
Monday night are the Titans an average
team are they going to be an average
team this year yeah yeah I I have a
feeling that they possibly could be and
I'll tell you why
you have to be able to produce explosive
plays in the NFL I don't care how good
you run the football and Derrick Henry's
a stud we know that all right but I you
have to be able to produce explosives
down the field you can't always have 10
12 13 14 play drives it's too hard in
the NFL you won't you won't score enough
points because the law averages will
catch up and catch up to you in terms of
you making a mistake turning the
football over whatever it is and the
Titans don't have that
not having AJ Brown on this on this team
is a huge huge huge loss it's huge
As Nice of a prospect as treyland Burks
is he's not ready for that spotlight
Nick Westbrook akina is not that kind of
guy they haven't been able to get Robert
Woods going in in the kind of role that
he has already excelled at what he was
with the Rams and when he was with
Buffalo before that
not having AJ Brown I mean that's an
issue that's an issue and I and you know
what and I don't even know if Derrick
Henry is the same Derrick Henry anymore
their offensive line isn't nearly as
strong as you would hope it would be for
them to be a run-centric football team
because the team that they played
against when you're talking about okay
after two weeks is are there teams that
have shown you this is who they are
Buffalo has shown you who they are
this isn't just some hot start that's
going to fizzle out they have shown you
who they are the Von Miller effect in
Buffalo is real
it is real we talked about it
extensively Monday it's real and I'll
tell you as nice as a of a coordinator
as Brian dabal is and As Nice of a coach
as he is and by nice I mean he's just
he's good I've talked to Brian many many
times he's good Ken Dorsey the new OC up
there who's the old quarterback coach I
like still coaches quarterbacks NOC
he is the real deal too man and they
have taken this organization to another
level with the addition of Vaughn the
addition of a physical running game and
the fact this team just feels like it
will not be denied it will not be denied
then and I I think look they're heading
for that big heavyweight Ali Frazier
Showdown with the Chiefs I mean it's
just it's just gonna happen
watch Game of the Year whenever they
play we got the bills and the Dolphins
are you where where do you stay no no I
know I know I know somewhere down the
line okay where do you stand on the
Dolphins
oh I love the I Dan I've been one of the
biggest
tuatanga Barlow and cheerleaders in the
history of cheerleading
and I really do like
what his headspace seems to be right now
and that is a direct reflection of the
fact that Mike McDaniel from day one has
said I am behind this kid 100 not in
just word but the
I'm gonna Back Him publicly I'm gonna
Back Him privately I'm going to get with
Chris Greer I'm gonna get with ownership
and say we have to support him with
better protection on the offensive line
better running backs and just a pleasure
you know just a just an absolute War
test of weapons on the perimeter and
they got all that for him and you see
now that he's healthy and now he's not
looking over his shoulder wondering if
Ryan Fitzpatrick's going to come into
the game or whether or not you know he's
going to get sold out in the media and
or talked about in a way that says that
he was way overdrafted he all of a
sudden now is playing like a kid who
looks like he's back at Alabama
now he's confident now he's moving in
the pocket finding marvelous he was
playing with great vision playing with
great decision making accuracy
and I've always liked their defense
Javon Holland they're starting free
safety I think is one of those unsung
superstars in the entire NFL
this team is hot this is a great
showdown in week three for them against
Buffalo it's a measuring stick for them
it's a measuring stick for them to see
just how far they've come because
Buffalo's for real if I said you could
have a previous quarterback Alabama
draft
so
moving forward I'll give you a tua Jalen
hurts or Mac Jones five-year deal
same price and and no we don't have any
offensive weapons
so you're on the clock now I don't have
any offices no no I mean I'm not going
to Define wait you got to sell it too
how about I put them all on the Patriots
they have no offensive weapons
if we're just starting from scratch I'm
gonna give you one now you build it out
around it yes yeah I got you
um
oh
look I wish you would ask me this like
three weeks from now
um Jalen looks like if if Jalen has
shown
a tremendous growth
if
his throwing ability
pocket throwing ability is for real and
sustainable
combined with how this kid can run the
football and we've already known them so
his dual circuit then
I probably have to take hip
wait you were in love with two uh that
no I know I know I know I know I'm
saying I'm saying though I'm saying
though that that Jalen has like that
that toolter came we we've seen what it
does to defenses and as a Defender I
know what it does to you as far as two
uh look
I mean that's that's such an unfair
question but I love it though it's
making my gears grind right now but yeah
it's um
because of but Jalen is just such a he's
just such a dynamic Runner but man if he
develops pocket presence like he showed
against Minnesota
oh man
um
of all three of them I think two is the
one that I think I I really do believe
that he was just he was born to play
this position because I think
instinctively
he just has it he may not have uh he may
not of the three
he may be
the
the least athletically gifted of them
all and that includes Mac even though
many people don't think Mac is a real
good athlete but he's a better athlete
than people think he may be the less
gifted of all three of them but I think
instinctively as far as being built to
play the position he's the one who's got
it all I do believe that
we're talking to Louis Riddick ESPN NFL
analyst he'll be on the call West
Virginia Virginia Tech tonight that's on
the mothership at 7 30 Eastern he was
also in the Monday night booth for the
Titans and the bills Packers Buccaneers
this is
okay I think with the Bucks because of
the fact that
Mike Evans isn't going to be there
people wonder and I wonder just how much
does it slowed down the explosive
component of their passing game would
you have suspended Mike Evans for a game
yeah probably okay I probably would have
just to make sure we can keep a lid on
those kind of outbursts happening and
because of the history between him and
Marshawn regardless of who you think is
the blame for that always escalating but
those two go at it every freaking game I
mean they go at it but can you be mad at
him can it no because you're he's
protecting Brady in a situation like
that no
white guys do that and I get I mean it's
not like Tom was in some kind of
imminent danger but I but I get it but I
get that's how people react towards
their quarterback I get it but I think
with Mike it might just need to
understand that you know because of how
volatile and how combustible his his
dealings with Marshawn Lattimore have
been he needed to let somebody else go
do that
or he just needed to be the one to not
have an escalate to that degree because
look I think Mike Evans I think Mike
Evans is one of the top three or four
wide receivers in the NFL we just don't
talk about him that way well he is and
he's too valuable to that football team
but great you know I think I think Tampa
Bay is uniquely situated to be able to
handle him maybe not be in there for a
game because of how physical their
running game looks how good Leonard
fournette has looked and how dominant
that defense looks and with Green Bay
I mean Green Bay could really be up
against it against his Tampa Bay defense
they really could although Aaron Jones
looked fantastic against the Bears and
and Aaron is starting to find his you
know he's he's gonna he's gonna get the
young guys coming around and their
defense
is stock I mean their defense should be
playing even better than it is
I mean they're defensive stock with
players I'll I'll go with Tampa in this
game
because it is at home for them
and because of how good their defense is
playing right now
all right I'll leave you with this are
the Niners in a better place this week
than they were last week
uh
we know well we know what place they are
in simply because we've seen this story
before we know what Jimmy brings and we
know how efficient Jimmy can be and you
know what so you know what's funny about
Garoppolo then is that
when Jimmy was playing
it was all about the Niners are never
going to be able to get over the hunt
because Jimmy hold them back when Jimmy
wasn't playing the Niners are never even
going to get there to be to even
disappoint about getting over the hump
because he he Trey Lance isn't good
enough so we went from crushing Jimmy
Garoppolo to now it was all about they
need to put him in there right now
because Trey isn't ready all right are
they a better team
are they a better team yes yeah okay
they probably are they probably are okay
they probably are and but I think and I
hate what what has happened to Trey I
hate it I love the kid I have been a big
supporter I do think he will take them
to another level because of his because
of his skills
but I I would I'd be lying if I didn't
say I was worried a little bit about
what his development is going to look
like now because of this injury
because I know how impatient people can
get with quarterbacks and next thing you
know they're on to the next thing
they're on to the next you know latest
greatest hottest Prospect I just hope
that he doesn't become a victim of of
that kind of mentality who's the best
quarterback you have an interception
from
True Blood cell
in the playoffs
1995 January 1st at about three in the
afternoon
yeah did you keep I remember it I
remember yeah I guess so do you uh do
you have the football
I sure do
I sure do would you get Bledsoe to sign
that like that is that unprofessional
information I I would I could get a hold
of them I could get his yeah I could get
a hold of him
he was he was a rookie at the time
um
and no it really wasn't because I think
what happened was he was trying to throw
the ball to Ben Coates over the middle
and he it was a little bit high and
bencoat's got the absolute crap knocked
out of him by one of our safeties Eric
Turner and so it really wasn't it really
wasn't Drew's fault I was just in the
right place
it was all good though but it was good
it was it was a great day in Cleveland
sports history though we beat the heck
out of the Patriots that's it great to
talk to you have fun tonight and uh I
will thank you buddy of course it's uh
Lewis Riddick ESPN NFL analyst he'll be
on the call with Matt Berry Harry Lyles
Jr III and uh that'll be Virginia West
Virginia and Virginia Tech 7 30 on the
mothership Saucy I like that